[Music]
hi welcome my name is kirsten moss and
i'm the dean of admissions at stanford
um and also oversee financial aid as
well
and today i'm excited for not one not
two but three reasons we have never done
a panel on our leadership curriculum
before this is an inaugural
excuse me
an inaugural event the first time
so and
in many the reason it's important to us
is many of our candidates say that one
of the reasons that they chosen stanford
or to apply to stanford is because of
our distinctive leadership curriculum so
it's exciting for the first time
to make sure that we can really share
what happens when you come to stanford
and think about developing your
leadership skills
and the third reason that i'm excited is
i am a certified leadership geek i guess
you would say and that's for the last
two decades i've been studying
leadership development and assessment
one of my most favorite memories has
been actually being a leadership
facilitator in one of our
elective classes here called
interpersonal dynamics for seven years
in addition to
being the dean of admissions here i've
also run career services at harvard
business school and finally worked in
the private sector in executive
recruiting helping coach senior leaders
and assess their talent and develop as
well so lots of reasons i can't wait to
hear what our students are going to say
today
so let's get started what are we going
to cover in the panel
today we want to talk about just
introduced briefly to our leadership
curriculum at stanford and then meet our
five panelists so this today is also
unusual because each of our panelists
are from the class of 2021 they just
graduated
woohoo and the reason
usually we have some alumni and current
students but we really want to get in
the
sort of meet the nuts and bolts of how
we develop leaders on campus so getting
five students who've just been through
the program will be really helpful
we'll kick up kick off with some q a so
i'll have some questions that i'll give
to each of the panelists and then we'll
save the last at least 20 to 25 minutes
to hear questions from you in the
audience so you can use your q a box um
as we go feel free to be adding
questions and then when the time comes
i'll start drawing from that list
all right
so let's let's ensure that we're can
introduce all of our panelists so brian
you can see their backgrounds we'll keep
this up while we do our introductions um
all from the classes i said of 2021. so
brian i'd love for you to get started
and maybe you could just tell us um
why you were thinking about an mba and
why you decided on stanford
sure thanks kirsten hi everyone uh
thanks for being here it's uh
great to be with my classmates again and
to all of you
um
the leadership development curriculum at
stanford is really the primary reason
why i applied uh i think as content
without going through the whole pre-gsb
resume i worked for nine years before i
came to business school and so the big
question in my mind was whether it was
worth coming to business school at that
point
and so i was much more interested in
applying to stanford business school
than business school generally and the
reason for that was because of the
emphasis on leadership development here
over the course of my career generally i
worked at bain before and then was at
the startup and in both of those cases i
had mentors who whom i just really
admired because of their ability to
develop others and the way that they
developed me um and what all those
people had in common is they had
graduated from the gsb and so when i was
asking them about
how they became the leaders that they
became they pointed to specific classes
that they had taken at the gsb as well
as classmates that they had who had
become lifelong friends and these were
mentors who were 15 20 years older than
i was and so um the gsb had always
loomed large as a place where you can go
and really
the school's focus on developing the
whole person was something that really
appealed to me uh so it was very much
because of this leadership curriculum
awesome thanks brian how about you
carrie
yeah hi everyone kerry here um i there
were three reasons for me for deciding
to go to stanford uh brian touched on
one which was the leadership curriculum
the other two reasons would be first and
foremost the culture i got the
opportunity to attend seminars like this
but not necessarily leadership
curriculum seminars but just get to
speak to current students and alumni and
it was just wonderful to hear about
people who are constantly challenging
one another but not in competition with
one another i think that's the spirit of
collaboration is something that i wanted
to be a part of and a bias for action
and kind of a willingness to embrace
failure as a way to grow so you fail
forward and learn from your experiences
and then the other reason the third one
would be the the stanford ecosystem more
broadly so i wanted to come to the gsb
partly because i would be at stanford
and stanford as you all know has so many
wonderful renowned programs so i'm doing
i did a dual degree program i wanted to
be able to interact with students from
other programs within the stanford
ecosystem so that was primarily another
reason why i chose to come
awesome thanks how about you sarah
hi everyone sarah it's really really
good to be here um i came to the gsb
because i wanted to start a company and
i really couldn't think of a better
place to do that
the seed was planted actually when i was
an undergrad at stanford so i did my
undergrad and my master's at stanford
then came back for round three for the
mba um and i just remember interacting
with gsb students in in some of my
classes and being really impressed by
the thoughtfulness that they put into
things like group projects or
communication and i i don't know i was
very impressed and bookmarked that for
later um similar to brian actually one
of my old bosses at a startup that i
worked at prior to the gsb was an alum
and i remember he had us all give a talk
and if you've heard of this tradition
called talk you actually give your life
story in front of the class and he had
us do that in front of our team which i
thought was really weird sort of
invasive um but it became kind of a
cornerstone of how our team gelled
together and how we really got to know
each other i've since gone on to become
a top coach while i was at the gsb um so
that was a big reason why i came with
sort of the influences that i saw from
my boss prior to gsb and then when i
wanted to start a company um i knew that
the gsb was going to provide me with so
many resources both in terms of personal
development but also in terms of the
startup itself um and that has
definitely proven to be true and i'm
happy to talk more about that
awesome that's great how about francisca
hi everyone francisca um so i decided to
come to gsb or business school generally
because my gre that i had taken five
years earlier was expiring and i really
had to apply in that one year
but beyond that um i i think in a word
growth um
growth in terms of career i was working
at a nonprofit in vietnam that was
terribly mismanaged and i knew that the
next time that i worked in an
organization like that like i wanted to
know how to make things better
who i think in terms of um personal
confidence like
and confidence i'm saying that broadly
like understanding myself truly and
deeply and knowing what i wanted uh was
really key and also the confidence to go
out and get it
um and then three i would say growth in
terms of personal wellness like i i
thought a big thing for me for business
school was taking a step back and
looking at my patterns and looking at my
habits and kind of rethinking how i
wanted to live
um and so
a lot of things leading me into business
school but stanford specifically some of
what our my fellow panelists have said
um the i think the focus on
leadership was important but also kind
of the the vibe that i got from students
um that they people were looking for
similar things to me and i thought that
would be a good environment to grow in
awesome thanks and how about you abby
uh thanks kirsten um hi everyone um i i
came to the gsb i think we've touched a
lot of reasons around leadership um mine
was also very much my basically my
entire decision to get my mba was around
uh leadership but i will highlight three
dimensions of it that i think were
important and for me and making the
decision so the first is that
um i wanted a place that was going to
force and push me to self-reflect and
think about what are my own strengths
and weaknesses and was going to help
give me both a
toolkit to do that self-reflection and
then kind of take that feedback and kind
of learn those things about myself and
apply them and actually have that sort
of really pragmatic aspect to it
um
the second reason which is more
aspirational and people kind of touched
on this but i had a really important uh
boss um in
in my work experience who had actually
gone to stanford and had been an
arbuckle fellow and a whole bunch of
things who i think is still probably the
single greatest mentor that i have and
is the first person i go to to bounce uh
decisions off of and and ideas off of um
and she was really good at i think both
determining kind of when to give me the
warm hug approach and one to give me a
little bit more of a butt kicking
approach and just understanding that
there's a whole array of tools that
matter and and kind of knowing a person
really deeply and being the person um
that i turned to and so i wanted i
wanted to be able to one of my biggest
aspirations career-wise is to be able to
pay that forward and to be able to do
that same for other people
um and so that was a big piece of it and
then the third and final thing is i
actually come from an industry that i am
kind of the the odd person out in the
room a lot i worked in sports um and so
often i would walk into rooms that were
heavily not looking like me it was often
very male
i was kind of the outsider and that had
a lot of interesting implications for
how i conducted myself at work and and
you know the groups that i was able to
be a part of and how i would influence
and figuring out how to master different
ways of doing that and how to lead a
room of people who weren't like me and
kind of that diversity in different ways
and how to respond to it myself or
really the reasons for applying
it's really helpful
thanks i'm gonna go
back um to one more slide here and i
love the introductions you gave because
many of you talked about this a moment
coming to stanford to turn inside
yourself and actually develop
who you are know yourself and really
that's what leadership our leadership
development curriculum is all about at
stanford the question we want you to
answer is why should someone follow you
maybe you're out there in the audience
and you're someone
who whenever you're in a room can kind
of distill the critical issues people
are speaking about or maybe you're
someone who's willing to challenge the
sacred cow challenge assumptions or
maybe you're the person in the room who
notices that someone else isn't
participating participating and you
include them and ask them hey i'd really
love to know what you're thinking so all
these are different leadership behaviors
but we want to help you answer that
question of what are you doing that
you're doing really well but also
understand the language of leadership
enough to
begin to grow into these other behaviors
and after studying leadership for 20
years both in the classroom academically
and then also in the private sector one
thing is very clear to me that
leadership cannot be learned from a book
it can't be learned from a case you
actually have to go through the
uncomfort and
the stress of trying on these new
behaviors and understanding things about
yourself you haven't seen before in a
really safe environment so we do that in
many ways at stanford from the core
curriculum and leadership labs to some
of our electric our elective courses
that you'll hear about today you can see
listed and even more structured
opportunities whether they're
extracurriculars or something like
arbuckle fellows low keynotes or talk
programs so i'm sure each of the
panelists will give us some of those
highlights so with that introduction
i'll stop sharing and i'm gonna
now ask the panelists a few questions
i'm going to have ask each of you to
start out and really if you can think
about the one class experience or even
resource that was most critical in
helping you with your own leadership
development while you're on campus in
the last couple years i'd love to hear
that and um abby maybe i'll start with
you we'll go backwards this time
yeah and i mean there's a lot of there's
a lot of things if i had to pick one um
gosh i think i would say um there was a
class called paths to power that i took
my uh second year in in the winter
quarter and and i think that for a
combination of timing reasons and that
you've gone through it at the point in
which you take an elective like that in
in the uh winter quarter of your second
year you've kind of gotten a little bit
of a foundation in terms of some of the
leadership things you've gone through
lead labs in the fall of your first year
there's often a lot of other
opportunities you had
up to then including things like i was
also a fellow et cetera but the timing
of it i think was really helpful because
it was a really good way of
consolidating and reframing a lot of the
things i've learned in one class and
being very pragmatic about how do you
apply some of these things um and i
think that the biggest takeaway for me
of it which was a bit of a shock to the
system at times but also helpful is that
um
when you're given a toolkit whatever it
might be
um it's a lot of it's a lot of uh
you have a lot of power with that right
of the ways in which you deploy it etc
um and that gives you the responsibility
to be intentional about it in terms of
everything that you know everything that
you've learned and these skills you have
you now have them and the ways in which
you apply them you have to own
um whether they end up being kind of the
right things the wrong things and in the
context of things like power there are
questions that you get asked around like
how much do you want to assert yourself
in a room or a space and you know and
will that result in how will that impact
a certain relationship or how will that
impact a certain thing and there are
going to be trade-offs and and part of
that is is you get to be you have this
toolkit where you get to assess all the
different options and you have to you
kind of have to be really intentional
about the the ways in which you go about
it and own those decisions and again
you're not going to be perfect every
time but it's about kind of ownership of
that and saying like there there is no
one perfect way of doing it but you have
to be you have to own and take
responsibility for the ways in which you
engage in whatever that setting and
whatever your goal is um so that was a
really good
uh learning of like it sounds corny but
like with great power comes great
responsibility right when you have all
these things that you're given in that
toolkit
it's a lot and and and figuring out the
ways that that you're comfortable with
owning that or it that's kind of the
critical piece of you have all these
ways that you can make a decision
the thing is that you have to be able to
live with that decision however it is
that you make it
that's great thank you abby how about
you sarah
so i think the class that impacted me
the most is called lean the lean launch
pad and there's actually a class out of
the school of engineering but it brings
together multi multi-disciplinary teams
across engineering business school all
over the university to start a startup
in one quarter it is really intense and
it was so it was the first time it was
our winter quarter so we were so new we
didn't know anyone and we had to put
together this team and then every single
week basically had to pivot because
nothing went right most of the time
and i think one one key lesson that i
take away and still practice today is
when how to make decisions and when
should you make a decision based on
consensus and when is that actually not
appropriate and for me that was a huge
learning because i was a product manager
before the gsb i didn't have any formal
authority and so a lot of my decision
making i thought had to be done by
consensus and so that's how i approached
this in lean launchpad and it created
a lot of interesting dynamics within the
team there's a lot of places where it
wasn't effective and so one key learning
for example is we would we started
making decisions by each coming in with
a really well-formed articulated
hypothesis and argument and instead of
asking people to vote we would have
everyone essentially debate around the
table and then ask people what is your
conviction on a level from one to ten
um and then on some decisions you know
we decided actually this person is the
owner and they're going to own that
decision and so how do we um how how we
navigate decisions and how uh teams are
collected and formed were huge learnings
through that class that i never would
have gotten if i just
hear a point kirsten read a book read a
case um seeing it play out in real life
was so powerful wow and that's so cool
too because it's a class that i don't
think of is typically the leadership you
know as part of the main leadership
curriculum but fascinating that's
awesome how about you carrie
and it can be a class experience um
resource anything you like
nothing i'll go on the experience part i
think
i i was fortunate enough to serve the
student body as co-president uh and
student government was not something i
had envisioned myself doing prior to
coming to the gsb so it was definitely a
stretch experience but it was a perfect
opportunity to take everything we're
learning in lead labs in in all the
other leadership curriculum classes why
should people follow you and put it into
practice in real time so for instance i
got to work on my communication skills
especially in the middle of a pandemic
where you have to be talking to people
about things that no one really knows is
about so that was something that was
important for me learning how to
delegate responsibility building
camaraderie amongst my peers practicing
empathy especially at the time everyone
needed it putting yourself in the shoes
of others and understanding how best to
support them so that for me was
definitely the experience that i know i
will be using in 10 20 years even when
you have a crisis just knowing how to
function during that time wow yeah and
carrie others may not know this but you
were really the student representative
on many of the decisions on the
committee that made many decisions about
how to get through the pandemic with
classes and everything else is that fair
description
it was it was a it was a wonderful kind
of collaborative experience where i got
to become really good friends with the
with the administrators the deans the
staff understanding the people behind
the scenes that make the gsb just the
magical place it is was also a wonderful
experience for me yeah not any not an
easy job i'm sure this year
how about you brian what's most
memorable for you
um
you know i was thinking i i agree with i
also was just typing in that carrie's an
incredible leader and we were so lucky
to have him as one of our presidents so
plus a million
um
the
i think we're all kind of avoiding
talking about touchy feely because
that's the big one that everyone knows
about but the reality is like that's a
great class and there are a lot of other
classes where you get to um apply that
same experiential learning cycle where
you can say hey um
let me make it concrete i think for me
the big realization for me was that
leadership is not a it's not like a
personality style it's not like you have
one fixed um
leadership type it's actually a suite of
behaviors and you can try on different
ones and some of them may be muscles
that are underdeveloped and you need to
practice some ones you just may not like
using like abby's talking about the past
how you may see different approaches and
see the results that gets them and say
hey i don't like using that one either
because it's uncomfortable and maybe you
examine why it makes you uncomfortable
and maybe you decide that's just not
going to be one of the ones i'm using um
so the class that actually gave me the
most of those learning cycles was uh the
negotiations class through the loss
and so this gets that like you can
there's a negotiations negotiations
class in the gsb as well i just happened
to do a seminar in the law school that
was a full corner and what was really
cool about that is every single week you
had a in-depth negotiation where
different class members had to play
different roles and um you would
explicitly reflect beforehand on what
your approach was going to be and why
and then at the end of the class even
though you were only in your negotiation
everyone would enter in the outcomes and
you could see the full range of
different approaches people had taken
and how it had gone for different folks
and you basically realized there's no
right or wrong approach but there are
trade-offs that abby's talking about and
trade-offs that you have to be willing
to own
and as you think about going into
negotiations in the future and these
aren't just high stakes one these are
any kind of negotiation about like where
we're going for dinner that's not in
class but you think about things um
it was really a really valuable way to
practice that
these action impact models that you
learn and as an article fellow or when
you're choosing okay what new behaviors
am i going to try on what
how do i expect this to land on the
other person and then you know in what
ways was i surprised and like what was
different than i expected and how do i
want to change my behavior next time in
order to better align uh my actual
impact with my desired impact and so
that class was the one where i just got
the most reps and and probably learned
the most from doing
awesome and um one of the things
stanford's known for is being able to
take what we call them classes across
the street because you can take them in
any of the graduate schools so maybe a
little brian about was that hard to find
the course take the course how easy or
hard was that oh it's super easy um that
class was one where just i think talking
to other classmates about hey if i want
to practice if i want to you know get
some reps doing something like if i'm
uncomfortable negotiating i actually
think it was sarah who was the one who
recommended it to me
oh my gosh this one's great and i
remember kind of geeking out with her at
dinner one night hearing about a
negotiation she was preparing for
and i just took it the next quarter
but it's really easy to do those i also
i think folks will do classes in the ed
school and a lot of us take a
computer science class just because
you're at stanford you can try something
totally different so it's really easy to
do that and it's a great compliment
awesome that's great and francisca
sure i
i think the one that really crystallized
for me was
like almost the very first day you at
the gsb you do this um desert survival
exercise where
um basically you're put in a room with
fellow peers and you're told that you
landed in a desert and you have to
choose and prioritize a list of stuff
that you take with you and i'm not going
to tell you what the right list is but
it's kind of a surprising like array of
things that you should prioritize
um and
afterwards um you're recorded and you
watch the video of yourself doing it and
you kind of talk through it and
the the group that you're with ends up
become is your leadership labs group
that you're with for an entire quarter
um and i guess that
even just like in the first week allowed
me to kind of like meta reflect on who i
am in groups
and who i want to be and like what are
the gaps there
um and then later on i decided to apply
to be an arbuckle fellow which i guess
we'll talk about later but
then i got to leave groups through that
exercise and think about okay
you can't change essentially who you are
but you can try to see like what can i
do to enhance how i show up in groups
and how i show up as a leader and i
think it's just it was just like right
away hit me in the face like what you
know it was going to be a learning
journey
francisco would you mind sharing
something to make it because that was a
wonderful example to make it concrete
for the audience is there something you
learned about how you showed up that you
um put into or you worked on or
developed more or is that too personal i
want to be no yeah i'm happy to so
you know
my group was uh
like right away one of the guys came in
military background he's like i got this
like
cracks knuckles like gets to work um and
he was totally wrong about everything he
was really apologetic for afterwards
um but i realized like throughout the
whole time
i was i was like i was like hey guys
like our time is tight like we got to
keep moving how about we do this how
about we do this and it like
crystallized that i'm really process
oriented
and that is like an a very real skill
that some people have less of
and so it helped to put like words to
what kind of thinker and and like
presents i have and then also how to
like counteract what you know there's
the big ideas people or there's the
people who stay quiet and like how to
bring all those things and so that that
was my kind of journey was like
realizing that and then and then kind of
like focusing on that later and
enhancing that as a skill
awesome great um
we had one question coming from the chat
that i think captures i'd love to just
ask you i think it's a great question so
for anyone that would make can you
describe a time at the gsb when you were
pushed way out of your comfort zone but
ultimately grew in your leadership
skills because of it so we got a little
taste of that from francisca anyone else
want to
take that on and all of you have had
incredible leadership development
opportunities on campus anybody want to
answer that
yeah i can i can go ahead and great
love
um yeah so in your first quarter in uh
in uh at stanford you take a class
called lead labs which is the class that
franciscus talked a little bit about
with the desert survival activity
and actually around week i believe it's
like week five or six of the curriculum
you do something which is um feedback to
everyone in your squad to you you have a
squad i think it was mentioned of like
six people or so and then an arbuckle
leadership fellow which is a second year
who helps kind of facilitate
and
and in that feedback session you you
kind of talk about like who makes you
feel hurt and who makes you feel seen
and and i had a member of my squad um
who
it's not that anything had actually
happened like there was no real conflict
or anything like that
um but i said to him and i feel like
sometimes you dismiss me and um that you
don't like me and i get and i don't know
that that's true but that's something
that i have internalized and i and i
don't know why and i don't know if
that's true but it's something that i
feel
um which was a really scary thing to say
aloud because again like i said there
was no real conflict it was just like
the sense that like there was something
there and i couldn't really explain why
it existed but it did
and it turned into the probably still
the single most productive conversation
i've had at the gsb which was um this
person who is from a very different
background from me looks very different
from me has very different kind of
interests passions etc looking at me and
saying like
you're right i've kind of felt the same
thing too like and again they're not
been like a major fight they're not even
been like somebody saying like you said
something to me that i didn't like there
was none of that it was just
um you know i've had this impression of
you since you walked in like you're a
blond-haired blue-eyed like big
personality like kind of likes to fill
up a room
and um i just figured that we would
never be friends and that you and i
would never like really actively spend
time together and that you were gonna
just occupy a completely different space
than i was
um and so i decided not to prioritize
getting to know you more etc
and that started a whole conversation
right around like impressions that we
had of each other
um and what that meant um and it got us
to a really powerful place i would say
of like
friendship and he's still someone that
i'm actually probably very very close
with the gsb who checks me on a lot of
things and i check him on a lot of
things um but i think it drove a couple
of lessons for me that were really
important i think the first was that
like um
weirdly like especially when you're
talking about soft skills or kind of
these like other core competencies that
we don't talk about where you can't like
name something in a spreadsheet like
often like what you're feeling or your
instincts like even though you can't
name them it might be like oh it's not
like this thing that i can explain
logically like that doesn't make it any
less real or any less present at that
time and it's something that like i
think as a leader has to be acknowledged
even if you can't quantify it
and i think too
it really taught me how to like
start thinking about conversations that
are really difficult and scary to have
around like
what is going on between us and talking
about naming that thing and then having
a really difficult conversation around
it that's ultimately very productive and
has led to some very close friendships
but again is like a really scary thing
to do in the moment
um and then finally it like really kind
of like hit home for me a couple of
things that um
that i need to recognize about myself in
any situation that i show up in which is
that i show up in a very certain way i
am somebody who can be pretty loud and
is willing to speak up first and i look
a certain way and i dress a certain way
and i act a certain way and that can be
very approachable and very warm and
friendly to certain groups of people and
to others it might be very alienating
and understanding okay what are the
situations in which this might be
alienating and how do i want it it comes
back to kind of owning the decisions you
make of like i like to show up this way
it feels like an expression of myself
but then for someone to whom that
doesn't resonate with them how do i want
to engage with that and how do i kind of
you know show up for them and how do i
approach them and thinking about like
with every kind of again every choice
you make you are bringing people in but
you also might be kind of throwing
people off and so thinking about that
very deliberately and knowing that
that's something that that happens even
when it is just showing up in a
classroom and being like hi good morning
and being very excited and knowing
that's not everyone's style and so
getting a sense of that and knowing that
that's
choices that you can make and that you
can kind of lean into i think was really
powerful for me to learn and it started
very early
wow thank you abby for sharing that all
right i'm gonna um anna yee had a
question that was very similar to
another one i was going to ask
basically any thoughts or
insights on how you thought about
leadership before coming to gsb versus
now so similar to where abby was going
but some a big learning or aha and how
did you get there
so anyone can go next how about you
brian yeah this was a this was a big aha
for me um
i
had applied for the arbuckle program uh
because of this curriculum on teaching
you how about leadership coaching in
particular and
um i think when i had applied to that i
equated leadership coaching with
managing or mentoring and um
can i jump in for a second brian will
you explain i don't know that everyone
in the audience knows what an arbuckle
fellow is so it would be great for you
to give the top level too that's great
so high level uh we've we've talked a
lot about this leadership labs class so
that is a first quarter class that every
mba one takes and that has led each of
those squads of six people is led by one
second-year mba um and they're they're
not the teacher in that class they're
kind of a facilitator and in order to
facilitate that they are those those
second years are called arbuckle fellows
um and you have to apply for this
program and
um if you are
selected as an article fellow you take
touchy-feely your spring quarter of your
first year so you get to take a little
bit early and then um your second year
you're doing three different things uh
like kind of three parallel tracks that
are part of leadership development the
first is you're in a class called
leadership coaching which is a
two-quarter long class where you are
like you know having regular weekly
sessions with readings on academic
content related to leadership coaching
and in parallel to that you're also
having a hands-on practicum which from
the leadership fellows perspective means
you are learning by trying to lead the
squad
and i think from the first year's
perspective i thought oh this second
year really knows what they're doing and
i really admired my leadership fellow
from the second year's perspective
they're like i have no idea what i'm
doing but i'm learning a lot because i'm
messing up
um but it actually is a very hands-on
way of learning about leadership
coaching by doing
and the third is that um so track one is
content track two is practicum the third
is about a community where you're with
you have a uh it's not called a squad
but it functions like a spot where it's
six that's five other arbuckle fellows
who meet and that's weekly and you're
sharing about your learning challenges
uh and getting support and one-on-one
coaching uh over the course of this
curriculum so it is a pretty rich
three-quarter long starting in the
spring of your first year and continuing
through the winter of your second year
where you're getting like classroom
learning hands-on learning and peer
support um and there's a longer answer
but does that that's helpful yeah thanks
brian
so your learning was yeah okay so my
learning was um leadership coaching is
totally different from managing or
mentoring and a lot of times uh the
latter that's managing mentoring is
about you know optimizing performance
helping people achieve your short-term
goals and coaching is much less about
achieving the short-term performance
goals as helping the person that you're
coaching
discover the answers for themselves and
fundamentally it's about
expanding their sense of the choices
that are available to them helping them
decide which choices are most uh
appealing to them and helping them feel
build confidence in their ability to
pursue those choices and it's really
about not telling them what's best not
giving them advice not even like
being anxious to reach the right answer
it's about like helping them explore the
landscape and helping them grow in
self-awareness and helping them grow and
feeling
capable of trying on these new behaviors
and a lot of that i guess to go back to
that colette's earlier question about
going way outside your comfort zone a
lot of the things that a coach can do is
help identify areas that are just a
little bit outside of their comfort zone
but that might then let them try a new
behavior that's not super scary but it's
in that 50 15 stretch zone and those are
the ways that a coach can really help
and it's super different from you know
being a mentor or a manager and so that
was a real um expansion of mindset for
me
that's cool thank you brian um we've
gotten a couple questions already from
the chat i want to make sure um
who is our sarah you're a talk coach we
haven't talked at all about that i think
that's such a cool part of our
leadership development would you mind
maybe talking about its influence on you
and how you became a coach sure um so
talk i briefly mentioned it but it's
essentially this tradition where every
single week two members of the class
will get up either in person or later
virtually and share their life in 30
minutes so it's just an incredible
tradition because 30 minutes is a long
time um and so and people are so open
and vulnerable and generous with their
with this community and really opening
up and sharing who they are and it's not
professional it is deeply personal um
for me as a coach i wanted to do it
ironically because i did not want to
give my own talk but i loved the idea of
talk and i was like i'll let others go
i'll support them and i did not realize
that top coaches have to give a talk
um and so i got that out of the way
pretty early and it giving a talk itself
was really transformational when else
you have the opportunity to re-examine
your life make sense of it and then
share it with a room
um and i think being a coach for me
i think to brian's earlier point it's
not like i used to be so focused on like
okay there's an out output that we're
all creating here there's a 30-minute
talk and i'm going to get you there and
here are the steps and i sort of halfway
you know through the fall quarter
stepped back and said it's
about allowing this person to have space
to answer questions for themselves and i
can be a mirror back to them um and so i
think about that for coaching broadly in
being really a mirror and someone to
help ask questions and guide but
ultimately it's their process it's their
output um and i'm just
always blown away by the talks we hear
every single week even if i've heard it
five times i'm still in tears every
every single week
it's been really special for me
awesome and just to keep you on the hot
spot sir for a minute longer one of the
things i love about stanford is we think
about leadership is also building your
brand and being able to communicate so
talk is part of that knowing what you
value who you are you also did low-key
note and you were ta for winning writing
i remember any so you've had a whole
brand building experience any highlights
on those two things as well
yeah thanks for bringing those up so on
the keynote in particular that was
exactly why i did it um so low keynote
for those who don't know is sort of a
ted style talk that you can give and you
do at the big stage at cmx auditorium
it's really you know high production
value oh thanks francisco
um
and i did it on a topic that is really
near and dear to my heart is how we
should reimagine aging in the process of
growing older it's also really strategic
because the startup i'm working on is in
the aging space and so i wanted to have
a piece of content out there that was
really professional that i was really
proud of that i could put it on my
linkedin and you know send to investors
um and also
i don't think many people know this but
i actually do not like public speaking i
have kind of around it and so it was
also
yeah um it was also an opportunity to
push myself way outside my comfort zone
and deliver a nine minute really
rehearsed professional speech um and
it's it's been awesome for winning
writing um i love writing i actually uh
and abby was also ta for that class oh
awesome um
glenn kramon if you have a chance to
take a class with him would highly
recommend he is just
the best um and so for me it was more
about getting
the opportunity to spend time with glenn
uh that really drew me into that
opportunity
awesome and um the output of that class
i always find fascinating right because
you're writing opinion pieces is that
right yes so the capstone piece is that
you write an op-ed and glenn is a
reporter at new york times an editor in
the new york times and he will go above
and beyond to get you published like he
has i mean just outrageous email chains
like trying to get you published every
which way and he will go lay out over
his skis to do it for you um he's
amazing um and will advocate for his
students literally for decades after
they graduate
awesome thank you i'm going to start
switching now to the questions in the
chat so marco asked one and 10 others
said they'd love to hear the answer what
courses professors situations from the
gsb do you believe you will go back and
reference the most as you lead people
and companies going forward
so
raise a hand if that resume and and all
of you now all of you are working so
this should be becoming really really
real to you
anyone oh i'm carrying it into your hand
yeah carrie awesome i can hop in here so
one that i've actually had to
go back and reference has to do with uh
it's called strategic pivoting with
allison kluger and uh it also has alex
rodriguez the
baseball uh legend in as one of the
professors of the class and i think
what's really important about the class
is similar to winning writing it's about
understanding your audience and if you
want to be a leader any leader knows
that you have to know the people you're
leading
and i think every time i have to do
stuff i'm currently on like a short-term
internship in sports and understanding
exactly who i'm speaking to and
understanding how to get buy-in and
exactly how i want to sell myself
because we all contain multitudes as as
leaders and your different parts of
yourself you want to bring as you're
trying to actually get buy-in regarding
different things so sometimes i'll go
back and look at the strengths i've
identified and figure out which things i
want to put at the fore of whatever i'm
trying to bring during a meeting and
things like that and that's actually
been very helpful this summer already
well that's great and um allison's
another example she was a tv reporter is
that right am i getting that right so
you'll see that at stanford that in your
second year electives they're often
co-taught by a tenured faculty member in
a lecture sometimes they're individual
courses like alison's teaching or
glenn's teaching but we like to bring
practitioners in as well as the
academics so you it's both the art and
the science of how you need to lead
that's great thank you let's go to
another one what has changed about your
and this is from
syed i i hope i'm saying it right yeah
what has changed about your leadership
style due to your experiences and
learning at the gsb now a couple of you
abby already had given us an example
friend francisca tell us
yeah i think so i worked in
international development before and i i
had to like pres i was a young woman i
had to present a really like
professional image which i i think is
important but i kind of came in thinking
like i had two hats i had like personal
francisca and then i had professional
franciscan like they were kind of
two different things there were some
similarities but not really
um and
i i realized like how much at the gsb
and some people come in just knowing
this they're just themselves always i
was not
um that like collapsing those two ideas
and kind of showing yourself
fully to you to different teams and
showing up
truly as yourself and sharing of
yourself
i know like this is entirely the
stereotype of gsb that it's like very
touchy feely but it is exactly what i
learned which is like
um when you show up fully
and that doesn't mean like revealing all
of your secrets all at once or whatever
but um there's a power to it because it
models what is okay for others and as a
leader
like what you show and what you share
and how you share it
um it kind of sets the tone
um and i saw that like over and over
again like
even with this i was part of the
hispanic student business student
association or even just like in
interactions with peers like there was
just a lot that like
when you kind of share your inner
thoughts a bit more and like let people
in on like kind of how you're thinking
about things um there's a power to that
and that
that was definitely a change from like
kind of the professional facade that i
had before the gsb
francisca i find myself just nodding and
nodding and nodding after being a
facilitator in touchy feely i think
that's amazing um
amazing response one of the things i
always say is we meet students on your
admit weekend so i get a chance to meet
all of you and then two years later as
you walk across that graduation stage
there's this sense of comfort in your
own skin and almost feels like some of
these masks have have come away i know
in touchy-feely that's how it felt but
anybody else who took that class want to
speak to this because i think it's such
a critical issue of how
how you learn to do that for yourself
through the class
do anyone else take touchy-feely
well yeah oh that's right all of you
okay who's going to speak up
on what they
what how that class gives you the
opportunity to show up as more human or
whole or authentic lots of the things
francisco said
i can jump in i i don't want to dominate
the discussion but i i'll i'll say very
quickly that similar to what francisco
said about bringing all parts of
yourself that's something that
if you're any form of a minority you'll
you may have experience knowing that
sometimes it can be difficult to bring
all parts of your identities to
to beer and i think being in
interpersonal dynamics you get to have
difficult conversations about how people
perceive you and why that has to do with
their perception of identity and also
being able to call it and have
conversations about why some some things
that may have been said may be
problematic or perhaps also bringing
understanding that um there's an
understanding of best intention but you
can still give feedback about how things
may land on you and i think that makes
you more confident in owning who you are
and walking into rooms bringing your
full self so that definitely was
critical for me as part of interpersonal
dynamics
that's great thank you
i might underline something that abby
said
the the story that abby told from her
lead labs experience was a lot of the
lesson that i took from touchy feely
which is that sometimes we
have feedback that we want to share and
we approach it as though we're building
a case and we're collecting
and you're only sharing the feedback
once you're sure you have an airtight
case
and that really means that you're not
sharing parts of yourself and so
sometimes um what touchy feely also can
push you is to provide feedback where
you don't have
evidence or if you're there's a line
that one of my facilitators said where
the feeling often arrives before the
thought and
you have a feeling and then you kind of
you do this very quickly so you don't
realize it but you kind of scramble to
dress it up in fancy language or and you
try and
give it intellectual clothing but
fundamentally you just feel sad or
undervalued or it's just something that
almost feel you're almost embarrassed or
ashamed of because it's such a simple
feeling but um naming those impressions
or or at least naming them to yourself
if not naming them you know if you're
saying hey i'm feeling dismissed here um
can often
provide opportunities for you to make
yourself more known but also to like
build a stronger relationship with the
people that you're working with and that
um
as fluffy as that can sound that can
build allow you to build trust and it
doesn't mean you're suddenly revealing
all parts of yourself but you're
incrementally building stronger rapport
with the people that you're working with
regularly and so that was a really
powerful learning for me as well
brian is there a way i put you on the
spot i just realized some people might
not know how the class works is there a
really short high level answer i know
it's hard to describe but for someone
who's never heard about interpersonal
dynamics before
yeah um i think like one way to think
about classes at the gsp is there
i've kind of been looking through my
notes since graduating and it's like
there are three types of classes they're
the ones where it's like a new
industry maybe and you're getting a
glass bottom boat tour of an industry
that was unfamiliar for you for me that
was like education like the education
industry there are other ones where
you're learning uh news gets new sets of
tools and you're trying something out
the first time and you're getting lots
of reps like that negotiations class or
building as a corporate financial
modeling class where you learn to build
an lbo model from scratch even if you
like never worked in finance uh there's
a third one where it's like um
and this is the last category where it's
like a new lens for seeing and
understanding the world and i think
touchy feely kind of straddles the
second and the third one you're learning
a new ways of thinking about the world
you're looking at your interactions and
you're kind of all of a sudden see
you're seeing them diagrammed in your
head of like what happened oh this was a
bit like this was a attempt to connect
with me and i missed it and so now i
feel like i'm going to be more attentive
to that and then you're also having
these experiential uh practice loops and
so the way that's structured in the
class is you have lectures once a week
where they walk through some kind of
content around like um
i mentioned bids like this idea of what
is the emotional unit of communication
and the smallest building block of that
is something that's called a bid which
is defined as like
any attempt to connect with another
person it might be you know telling a
dad joke or smiling at someone when you
see them and you know it's just a
question of does a person acknowledge
that or not and this is just a new
vocabulary a new way of thinking about
things and then after these lecture
classes you go into what's called a t
group which is your your learning group
it's 12 people and you spend um
something like seven hours in a room
together without any like clear agenda
or structure and just uh
communicating and a lot of what happens
in there is sharing the um
either providing feedback to people or
sharing reactions to the ways that
people have landed on you either in that
session or in the past and it's a one of
those hands-on experiential learning
courses where you really do push
yourself to
share feedback that maybe is a little
more direct than you're used to giving
or that reveals a little more of
yourself than you may be comfortable
with um and those
relationships become very strong
actually um i'm
um i'm i'm working with someone who was
in my uh t group uh when i was in touchy
feely because that that relationship
became a like a pure coaching
relationship that continued past that
class and
um
it was a really formative experience for
me
awesome that's great okay i'm going to
read another one this from dieter
through these events i've heard a lot
about professors being engaged outside
the classroom with students professional
aspirations and business endeavors does
this hold true with leadership
development or is that primarily done
you know student to student more so how
are professors of well you could answer
generally how professors um sort of
empowered you along your two years and
also specifically if they've touched you
in the leadership side
anyway abby yeah i'm happy to take that
i mean i think on a broad level we've
talked about i know people have
mentioned different professors here like
glenn kramen's a great one i still talk
to him all the time i work in marketing
so he's a great person wrong writing by
et cetera
and i would say i think one that
fostering relationships with professors
with gsb is one of the
i obviously knew coming in that would
that it was a good idea but i don't
necessarily know that i realized how
good an idea was until i started using
them and leaning on them um i think i
mentioned i've already started working
i'm at a startup where i'm now managing
a team of
um eight people now we just hired two
more and so
and it's my first experience in a
startup environment i think for one i
and when i've managed people before it's
been in a much more structured setting
and so in terms of thinking about
leadership and trying to one deploy the
lessons of leadership and thinking about
my role as less of a
like purely like hey so and so please do
this and thinking about them as you know
creative resourceful and whole human
beings that i want to help develop and
make successful and there's also quite
frankly like leadership challenges that
just come up right like having um i
worked you know during part of the gsb
as well but having people who are not
performing and having to kind of you
know have conversations that are really
tough around that and um having
conversations when like i don't feel set
up for success that um
[Music]
it's much more nuanced than it used to
be of like i don't feel like i have the
data i need to fix this problem it's
much more you know structural across the
organization or things like that because
we're building a company we're building
a culture
and and i can tell you that there are
gsp professors who i lean on quite
heavily for this so um a big one is is
ricky frankel who is one of the uh she's
one of the arbuckle leadership fellow
program leads and
she was my when i was a fellow she was
my clinic leader and kind of is just a
huge huge mentor and coach of mine um
and she's someone who i have role-played
many of these conversations with both
while i was at school and actually since
graduating school although it wasn't
that long ago not that far removed but
still having those conversations and
herb grisbeck's another one who i have
um he teaches a course called
conversations and management which is
really around like how do you think
about the different ways of having
difficult conversations what are the
assumptions that you're making how do
you think about them differently and
he's someone who i've had a lot of
correspondence with in starting this
role as well of how do i think about
this problem what are the things that
i'm missing where are my blind spots how
should i actually like can we role play
this conversation and doing some of that
i can tell you it's like incredibly
practical and very much applicable to
the work that i am doing right now um
and so in some ways i consider myself
very blessed because i have a reason to
email those people all the time and but
it's also it's truly an important
resource that i have leaned on a lot as
i've kind of got my
my as i'm getting my feet under me in
the in the post-school world
how about we wrap up and i'll go right
down the panel any um
tips many we found out 90 of folks were
planning on
applying this fall so any tips you might
have as they're facing that application
process
on things to think about if they're
thinking about stanford how about you
brian
oh um yeah well definitely apply i think
there's a lot of um
i think
being really clear to yourself and
taking the time before you write that i
think there's a lot of mechanical stuff
to focus on in the application and
that's all things that you will get done
but giving yourself a little bit of
space to think about you know what what
is it you really want to get out of the
experience because
you know
oftentimes people focus so much on
applying itself that there's just such a
richness of opportunity at stanford that
you can't just figure that out once you
get there and so knowing you don't need
to have a really deliberate clear plan
of you know abc more just saying if
nothing else what do i want to get out
of these this year and a half and how do
i want to change and what would be
something that i'd love to be able to
say about myself at the end of this
journey and just writing that down for
yourself you don't have to share with
anyone but that can help you once you do
get there and you have this huge volume
of things to choose from and how you
want to allocate your time that could be
something that you'd revisit that's
really helpful and that can often pull
you through the mechanical uh work of
actually getting through the application
process so good luck awesome thanks
brian sarah
i was going to say something similar to
brian just really thinking for yourself
what you want out of these two years
because it's an incredible opportunity
it's also the scary thing i found it
really intimidating to be like what do i
want out of these two years you know
it's a big daunting path so i got some
really good advice to think about it as
a hypothesis so come in with a number of
different hypotheses and this is also
how we run our startup so this is very
analogous but it's like you know i have
a the person i got this advice from had
a hypothesis that he wanted to be in the
coffee industry he wanted to work at a
fintech startup and he wanted to like
run a marathon these are not related
hypotheses but he systematically went
out and did each of those three things
and fell in love with the spin tech
startup and that's what he did after the
gsb um and so just taking an
experimental mindset to this and knowing
that you do have time you do have
bandwidth to experiment it's not all or
nothing really for me was a mindset
change and how i approached the
experience
thank you carrie how about you
well first of all i want to reiterate
brian's um
apply which with a shoot your shot
because for myself i know i was i was
there were many times where i wasn't
sure about getting into gsb but you
won't get in if you don't apply so 100
shoot your shot and try to get it i
think in terms of advice i would say
um two things one have grace for
yourself because it is a very rigorous
process and it can be it can be daunting
there are many times where i had doubts
but i think have grace and just keep at
it and then the second one is
try to immerse yourself into the
community in any way you can whether
that's attending programs like this it's
reaching out to um alumni current
students if you have any connections
whether it's second hand just try to try
to learn as much as you can about why
the program is right for you because
then it will come through when you apply
awesome abby thank you
yeah i'm trying not to reiterate all of
the the stage advice of my peers here um
and
i don't know many things but one thing
and i'm not the dean of admissions
either although she's in the room um but
one thing that i do know is um stanford
doesn't want you because you're perfect
um you're not going to be
the greatest leader ever because you're
perfect um
the people who you engage with and meet
with and become close to you and all of
these sorts of things it's not because
you're perfect
it's because you have the interesting
quirks and flaws and personality traits
and things that make you you and make
you lead in the authentic ways that are
you and that help you engage wherever
you are be at stanford or be it at work
wherever it is the things that make you
you and so the goal is not
perfection i think the goal is
to to kind of as people have talked
about and it's i think the start of a
journey at stanford right of starting to
embrace those parts of yourself and
knowing that you can bring all of that
together and so the goal it's so
interesting when you're applying to
think like i must be perfect and i think
actually the reason that everybody in
the community is so amazing and what
really stands out to me about it is that
everyone was an incredible leader um
because of their quirks not you know
despite them
love it thank you francisca we close
this out uh yeah i think first um
put in the work to be who you want to be
regardless of business school so
business school is just one step on the
on the path like if it doesn't work out
put yourself on that path whether it's
building habits getting to know people
looking
ahead of things because this is not the
end i'll be all it's just one step on
the way and the second thing i would say
is like stay off poets and quants and
all those like websites because they're
just gonna stress you out and they don't
really add that much value to
um your journey awesome
well thank all of this panelists for
coming here today i've learned a ton i
really appreciate it it's so wonderful
to see all your faces as well back
together and to all the um prospects out
there we appreciate you coming hopefully
you'll listen to the sage advice shoot
your shot i'll steal from kerry and i
hope to get a chance to read your
application this this coming fall thanks
so much
[Music]